so uh for today i prepared basically
another my analysis of um
the final from the uh
opera rapid between magnus carlson and
wesley saw
and today we will discuss
analyze our eyes and discuss
what happened between in the in the
match between those two
great players wesley saw managed to win
in the match and i wanted to
bring basically highlights from the from
their competition
because i think there were lots of
interesting moments in the in the match
and i wanted to share with you my
analysis
my kind of like thoughts about it and
discuss basically what happened or what
could have happened
so uh without further ado let's get
started
so um in the first game basically i'm
gonna
pretty much uh uh not gonna be we're not
gonna be talking about entire games
pretty much because there are eight
games to basically cover eight games in
one hour is pretty much impossible
especially with such strong players like
magnus and wesley
so i'm gonna pretty much show the
critical moments some
very instructive you know moments
whenever i think something
could have been played better or was
played very very strong and so on
so um let's let's get started from game
number one
so in the first game we got this
position um
so um in the i'm basically i'm going to
be asking you questions as well
so uh yeah so in this position
uh white played modern was played with
white and was played with black
so in this position magnus play move a3
and uh yeah yes bishop takes c3 queen
takes c3
that's happened in the game knight d4
bishop takes the d8 knight takes c3
uh bishop b7 uh rook e8 bishop d6
and knight x looking into z2 and
basically we got this end game which is
pretty much equal like pretty much
entire game was equal
and you know the
version pretty much simplified
immediately however to move a3
uh can you find a better move here for
block then bishop takes c3
is there might be a better move to start
with
why was the queen sacrifice okay where
was it sacrifice
uh quincy frequency frequent id4
uh it wasn't sacrificed it was traded
so i take but on the a but also black
takes on c3
and basically things are getting
simplified say bishop e7
hitting the rook i attacked the bishop
back you retreat the bishop
knight takes the bishop king takes the
knight and we got this position so
everything is equal
so it wasn't sacrificed come back into
his position in
what black to play in here
what black connection okay i will flip
this i'll flip this
black to play in this position what
would you do
huh
mj says maybe not c5 but no okay
king okay so angel you sort of doubted
you served out
yourself knight c5 and uh yeah knight c5
is the best move let's see 5 is sort of
trapping the queen
after knight c5 basically
the queen is in deep trouble right now
because of the queen b4
a5 those squares are taken under control
the queen cannot go there so queen
defies to be played and right now either
bishop a6 or bishop c6 both win the
queen
so basically yeah like here let's say
the queen is trapped and
you know black simply wins move number
what
13 0 1 so even be in the game between
you know such
players like magnus and wesley such
opportunities
occur and they sometimes go unnoticed
which is astonishing
i i find i find that strangely but you
know it means that
people are still people they are prone
to making mistakes
so um after a free
you know wesley didn't play an sc5 so
this was his big missed opportunity to
basically just cease that
uh leading the in the match this game
number one
that c5 was would be a huge tactical
blow right now to magnus right now
and uh basically why this black is just
much better because if quasi-2 or queen
d1 is a queen d1 and we could have
bishop take c3
we take c for saying id4 this is
horrible we are taking the
pawn structure is horrible we can also
take it on g5 maybe
black is just where black has just huge
advantage
so after and after quiz 2 it's just the
same thing but right now
e4 has to be played and the queen has no
better square than d1 because if queen
c1 there is no b3
also if queen d2 then also knight b3 and
black wins
so uh queen d1 will have to be played
but anyway we should take c3 be take c3
and let's say uh you know even h6 and
then we can play just anything
black has huge advantage
black has you know huge advantage in
this position
so um you know this was a huge miss here
by wesley so who didn't play a knight
takes knight c5
uh and the position after takes
frequency 394
all those trades became pretty much
equal
and they position remain equal for the
majority of the game
up to a moment when uh magnus was trying
to push for a win too hard
and he got in trouble so i want to talk
about this position right
last move magnus playing with g5 can you
find a really nice move here for black
f5
h6 two forces to open the g file uh
f5 is a blunder right it's just f5 8x5
h6 forcing to open the g file well i
think white wants to
open the g file uh black white play g5
uh why play g5 uh to open the king side
sort of so actually serve helping white
with this
wichita xb5 is a horrible move bishop of
b5
you know voluntarily creates you know
white a past past past supported past
pawn
on b5 so this cannot be any good
and h5 also is similar to h6
basically you do okay this is too
difficult i'm going to show you what
happened
basically right now west is played very
destructive and nice move of bishop e8
and the point is that bishop comes to f7
it's a i find it very instructive
because
bishop is similarly well placed on c6
but it finds even better locations f7
where it is supports oh sorry his
opponent c4 in case white goes ruby g1
or
g7 or i mean like anytime soon let's say
after g takes f6 she takes f6
uh g1 you know the bishop comes to f7
and basically the
reach of the knight never comes with a
check and poland c4 is always under
attack
so uh that's why uh bishop abc7 was a
very nice
maneuver here by wesley and this is what
happened in the game and right now
manus again was i think too ambitious
still
and he played a mistake okay him he made
them he made a mistake he was probably
supposed to
simply go back c1 and sort of you know
just hold the balance
and the position is pretty much still
around equal
perhaps black may be slightly better
because
it's easier to attack you know pawns on
c4 on light square c4 and
a4 with the bishop but still you know uh
black should be totally totally fine
y should be totally fine um everything
is well defended and
the knight has potential of going to d5
square uh
you know it's should be around equal
even if black is maybe
slightly slightly better objective here
is
close to a draw but manus played move
very i mean too ambitious he played too
ambitiously uh
he played rook to g7 so can you find a
move for black right now
use again uh missed opportunity right
now for wesley
because wesley made a mistake and after
this that game was even till the end of
the game
and uh the game was drawn however here
he missed
wesley missed a big chance to you know
really put huge pressure on magnus
okay two suggestions activate the rook
and king of eight
okay yeah that's pretty much it yes uh
and after
after king available thinking g8 the
group water was trapped
that's the point and the king of eight
group h7 king jr h16 g7 the game is just
over
white rook is trapped while black wins
so after
and after kiruk has to perhaps go back
to g1 but why would you play with g7
uh if you cannot just capture pawn on h7
right so uh
whistling was definitely a mistake by
magnus after king of eight
you know this is this attack this is
attacked you cannot take on h7 because
i will show it again on the board rook
is suddenly trapped
right and it has nowhere to go black
wins
so rook g1 has to be played but right
now uh
you know bishop takes c4 you know we
just win upon
and this was this would okay still
according to my analysis still
probably white can somehow manage to
save this
but it's becoming extremely extremely
difficult
um i don't think it makes sense to show
the variations right now because the
most important thing is just to find
king of a
and then we have a disposition just just
to play this
uh and we have lots of other games we i
would like to talk about and we are
still on the game number one so let's
move to the next one i think
uh but anyway this was a huge miss again
by by uh wesley what is funny
however after in this line if he he
could have basically trapped his
minus roblox with rook but
in the beginning of the game he could
have dropped his queen
right after queen b4 and a5 he would
have helped his queen and rook in the
one game
so it's kind of like rare but anyway
this is what what could have happened
okay so let's go to the next game and in
the next game uh
wesley was playing with white uh against
uh magnus
and the game was very interesting they
played
in italian game this version of
two nights basically after knight six
and g5 which is very very sharp
objective bug is doing well there but
you know
[Music]
it is it requires a lot of memorization
and
very accurate concrete play and
especially in rapid chess it's easy to
you know
mix up things so uh you know the
okay let's look we can see this game
like you know uh
from the from this moment uh d5 it takes
d5 knight a5 because it was all
theory or like some preparation here by
wesley c6 detect six beat x6 bishop d3
one of many moves knight d5 93 bishop
diseases oh this is all theory this is
called theory
one f5 black sacrifices material two
pawns
in order to look for counter play white
accepts the challenge
um retreats then g5 g4 is released
crashing however uh simple f4
knight f4 bishop f1 g4 similarly black
in the knight has nowhere to go but the
white is happy to sacrifice this knight
by playing d4 and after which takes the
free queen takes a free
white six sort of like uh counter play
and uh
making taking advantage of white sort of
black knights being sort of you know
loose on a5 and ec and f4 black plays
knight e6
and right now i think it was on novelty
or almost no it was novelty there was
one game having played
by queen c3 and um
idea is to hit the knight on a5 after
mp7 now c5
and the bishop c7 b4 basically
um yeah and after a5 play b5 so
basically we got to this position in
this position
uh magnus okay this was all preparation
here
by wesley because i saw the interview he
met just because on this topic
and here he analyzed only stakes b5 and
i looked into this line of myself by
myself and indeed
stakes b5 right now leads to equality
however uh you know in such position
when faced
unprepared and mine was clearly okay
for sure he knew the line but maybe he
didn't remember exact moves move orders
or something and or we mix up some lines
you know it's very easy to you know make
mistakes in such position so it was a
good practical choice here by
wesley who definitely caught magnus off
guard
so after b5
pawn on um you know uh hanging so
and the point is you know the pawn uh
white pawns in the center are very
strong black knights
especially knights uh are a little bit
kind of misplaced
on the especially then b7 is kind of you
know ugly looks
looks kind of ugly king on g8 also
doesn't feel really safe this white
bishop goes to c4 square and will be
very annoying pin so
in this position
in this position uh black uh magnus
playing with queen takes d4
and queen x4 is a big mistake
it was a big mistake uh and we'll i'll
discuss in a moment why
um okay actually
no actually i can start i can just tell
you immediately because and
after we discussed why it was a mistake
we'll see what was the best
play instead so quintex 64 is a mistake
because right now
what can i do let me ask you this what
can i do here
what is the best move for white
queen d4 rookie 7
i guess it's possible but
[Music]
it's not the best
not exactly sure why but i know it's not
the best
this is very complicated anyway
yeah bishop c4 bishop c4 is the best
move
correct bishop c4 is the best move what
happens in general in this type of
position
uh because of this 96k only we have two
key on g8 we have to make use of this
pin and that's why bishop c4 has been is
the best move
bishop c4 is the best move and after
queen execute knight takes e3 the spin
is
just extremely difficult to get out of
and the white is
nearly you're not winning your voice is
nearly winning i analyze it a little bit
i will show some one example line but
you know no matter what black dust white
is winning here
for instance uh what could be logical
let's say
uh knight xc5 seemingly is logical to at
least capture the pawn and
you know bring this knight to supporting
uh knight on e6 but right now another
pin is coming which bishop a3
and okay now so basically those pins are
just
crashing and it became if they will only
move seemingly knight e4
but then we can just take take and this
position is very very bad for
for um for black there are two pawns and
the
two rooks sorry rook and the two pawns
are much stronger than the
two minor pieces because black king is
extremely
uh bad position right now also only six
is hanging on
six is hanging positions open they're
all sort of open fast black pieces don't
have support
uh white white because of that otherwise
simply winning here
so uh this would basically just pretty
much end the game so again missed
opportunity for wesley
but
but he after queen uh
he played queen d4 queen d4 was a big
mistake because after knight takes d4
uh again still possibly uh he could have
wesley fought for better like here
inside the game of knight move knight c3
uh and i accurate finances still it's
white is worse but
sort of maybe holdable i want to go into
details because
some computer lines we don't care about
them
um after visual c4 seemingly very
natural move
right now magnus doesn't run away with
his king but he gives back the piece
and uh right now because of his bare
development of pieces
kinetic c5 uh you know rook c6 uh
doesn't work because e5 at least and you
know both pieces are not developed and
suddenly
only one is still just lost and black
wins
and if rugby is simply rook e8 knight c3
stakes b5 and because of those two pawns
on the king side
sorry on the queen side uh you know
black simply wins
because there's no way to stop them and
they're just
going forward there's pretty much no way
to stop them and
in the end i want to show one position
from this game
uh where i think mounts play something
very very instructive
so uh yeah let's say this moment uh
right now you know as i was saying upon
the
queenside pawns simply were going
forward and they went as in this game
so in this game uh inspiration wesley
play bishop d2 minus player should be
five
and uh bishop f4 because you know those
bishops this bishop supports you know a
one square
and if this you know without
with those bishops on the board is
impossible to defend this with white so
wesley tried to trade was bishop but
right now
uh magnus played
bishop takes a four which takes a four
and now one very nice move for black
what would you play i think it's the
highlight of this game
r2
after we tried this i go rook c3
a2 rook a3 let's say and i put my rook
behind the pawn
and i i think i can make a draw there
okay what happens after before what will
why what will why do after rook b4
just king
correct uh here's ruxin7
so where do you want to bring up your
king
well you can definitely bring up your
king but there is is not the most
technical way to
to win this the most technical way to
win this is to play no not king h65 no
no no
first things first uh chess king
suggested correct idea but his execution
was
wrong
what is h5 even doing h5 is a mistake
rook b8 similar to b4 but doesn't work
king is 6 possible but not the most
technical way to win this
possibly also wins because the king is
just super selective
correct rook b7 ruby 7
very nice move by magnus and basically
the idea of rupees
is to bring the rook to behind the pawn
with rogue a7 support respawn
and the most important not to give a
possibility for white rook to get behind
the pawn
not no rook c7 right now and the next
move will be through k7
black is just wins and other way to
follow re7 and
now we can bring the king and they were
playing a little bit and of course
you know eventually the king gets
through and
black wins and the black won the game so
in i'll show the final position
final position was this so
uh basically black king got through and
there was no way to stop this king from
going through
and you know here
white white uh wesley with white
resigned
so uh that was that was it so let's come
back quickly to the
move here with b5 so queen e4 was a
mistake that
actually brought the manus away in here
because wesley didn't react cor
properly but after queen d4 again uh
bishop c4
uh is this just crushing because of the
spin on the diagonal
so uh in the best way to play here with
black was to
play stage b5 be sure to take it b5 and
right now i
again idea for white split shot c4 we
should bring the bishop here
however uh the best move right now for
black is to play with a4 which is
extremely difficult to find over the
board whenever you don't know the
analysis or like when you then analyze
and whenever position is totally new and
fresh
but yeah the idea is to bring this
knight to a5 and
whenever the blue comes to c4 uh you
know ideally we can stop this bishop
from going to c4
or at least we can chase it away from c4
if if we can
so after which c4 knight a5 forces
bishop d5
rook b8 uh queen e3 i analyze rook e8
knight c3 bishop d7 and this position is
totally unclear
and uh you know engines give like zero
zero zero everywhere position is you
know just
according to engines is totally equal
however on human level this is just
total mess
i think both sides are taking risk here
um
yeah anyway this is what i wanted to
show in this game
after okay but anyway after magnus
wanted with this move a nice move again
i will show it
uh rook to b7 and bring rook to a7
he took the lead in the match and in the
next game he was happy with
just taking a draw uh with
berlin or you know exchange but we're
burning with rookie one and the game was
very very quick draw
we can skip this game there was not much
going on the game ended with some
repetition in such position after queen
3 and yeah just
going back and forth and was a draw and
the
mountains didn't make good use of his
white collar right now
with white and in the next game wesley
so took
his chance and played and played very
nice game
in uh italian game
[Music]
in italian so he present one
very nice idea as well so let's go
basically there so this is one of the
topical position in the
italian with dc3d4
and yeah right now there's a big theory
here i don't want to go into theoretical
discussion about this
but i like a new approach here by magnus
he played bishop g6 queen c equ
queen b3 this is all let's say have been
played knight 7 has been played
short castle c6 bishop d3 and now knight
f5
which is improvement over this game with
aaron when he when he played queen d7 i
think
and uh in 2020 i think still
uh but now that the five he played which
is an improvement i think
uh wesley played rare queen c2 but never
does pretty much
very testing and after queen c2 um
you know one uh magnus come i was
sure he was his i'm sure he was his
still preparation play
new move knight takes c3 so far has been
played knight takes e3
f takes e3 uh knight g3 but after
uh this simply bishop takes g6 h3 g6
rook f2 i think white has some chances
here because of the very strong center
and bishop on music is being sort of out
of the game
and because of that i think white has
some chances even though probably black
is okay here
however i think white has some chances
so
um that's why
magnus decided to play very fresh idea
and i take c3 another has not even
played
uh b takes c3 if bishop takes f5 uh
simply takes
queen takes a five knight e4 is totally
okay for black position just equal
however uh after bishop take after
knight x3 b takes c3
is better move now knight takes e3
fallout after ez3 bishop takes d3 queen
takes d3
and now uh manus played very strong move
f6
idea is to resolve the issue of this
bishop on b6 which
is here under out of play uh
okay thanks joe for saying uh i'll see
you around
uh bishop on b6 is a very bad bishop
right now it's hitting like a wall of
all spawns
and uh we need to somehow get into the
game bring into the game that's why the
best movie for black is to play f6
as what magnus did and right now um
wesley play move c4 which is a very
interesting uh
practical try even though objectively
doesn't give advantage
in my opinion i mean in general it's
hard to find an advantage here in this
variation for
for a while but i can try different
approaches and c4 is definitely one of
them
and uh he cut magnus of guard in this
position
because mars made a right now big
mistake so uh
i will ask you what to do here with
black because you know
even manus couldn't find it and it's
very difficult only with
analysis with uh engines and so on
proved to i mean show
how to you know get get equality here
which is not obvious let's say during
the game and um
and we have to sort of with some still a
few games to talk about
so um in the game follow bishop 7 which
was a huge mistake suddenly
and let's understand what was better a
better move was ftx e5
knight takes e5 and right now very
strong queen d6 i think this pretty much
equalizes the game
and the point is that um
first of all c5 doesn't work because
bishop takes c5 and design only five is
you know under attack from the queen and
you know blackwood simply wins upon
so and
and if city is d5 right now
the point is that we had to uh
get this good white knight to e5 square
and two in order to take the
recapture of the queen on d5 because
right now e4 is never possible
because knight 25 doesn't support the
center
and okay of course e4 for lose because
of wiki's diagonal of queen e5
and both queen d4 and queen if i win uh
just to show it quickly and this e4 is
obviously doesn't work and if d4 doesn't
work
there is nothing that the white can do
here e4 is the main idea and the queen
of divided
on d5 it secures you know entire
diagonal
and blocking is safe which was not the
case in the game which is a huge
huge difference and that's why here
after queen d6
uh i think position is equal the best i
thought try for white is to play move
rook fade rook fade rook f1
but again here after we have one queen
f1 uh
white threatens to go queen f5 or queen
f7 but black can deal with both frets by
playing with queen e6 cool move
but you know covers both squares ideas
basically bishop c7 keep the knight out
position just equal
but no problems here for black
whatsoever it's just
just equal maybe even in the long term
perspective bishop maybe will become
better than the night
i don't know probably not but um you
know it is
uh it's possessing just equal doesn't so
that's all i'm trying to say
um okay that's why after c4
f takes e5 knight take e5 queen g6
simply equalizes
and let's see what happened in the game
because minus play bishop c7 and right
now
after stakes d5 queen takes d5 c65 would
be
so we can create a weak pawn on d5 which
uh also you know be attacked very soon
that's why queen takes if i fall but
right now after he takes f6
after let's say rook takes f6 suddenly
this queen side
sorry the queen on d5 is getting uh
harassed immediately above e4
and the point is that uh including with
the with the position in such position
of bishop
on b6 knight on e5 black uh sorry white
cannot do this
right now it is possible because knight
is supreme is
pawn on d4 visually seven is actually
misplaced
it was we would we would have been
better players on b6 and right now what
his huge initiative and i think was on
the verge of winning that's after queen
f7 there is e5 or
even knight g5 it's y has very very
strong initiative also e5 is
probably very good and um
yeah so that's why uh you know in this
position magnus was
decided to take the pawn but this
creates a huge
hole on f5 and wesley comfortably
delivered the win here
uh he played e4 maybe knight h4 was a
little bit more accurate right now
blade then played another five but e4
doesn't support really anything
uh maybe you know marx would have
defined a little bit
better but nonetheless what is almost
pretty much everywhere uh much much
better and
wesley comfortably uh won the game c5d5
obviously we pushed the pawn forward
rook b1 stopping all kind of counter
play locating here on the light square
is very cool move king age one
in any case um to avoid any sort of
checks with bishop d4 and stuff
king h1 very useful move very nice idea
and after visual d4
uh simply ruger f4 the game is just over
so here marvelous just decided to give a
giveaway the exchange of bureau takes e4
but it is
uh not really saving anything and
because his king is just so
weak and yeah so
bishop if we should be five let's say
beerus g4 foreign decisive
after this rook g8 blue jade and d6
uh analyzed and basically white is just
crushing
this this sorry this is never possible
because of the pin
uh yeah this is just uh just just
winning
this person just running after you know
k1 this is just winning
already so um
miles tried this to you know get some
maybe practical
conor chances but after rook one the
game is just over
and the game is the end with nice rook
g4 threatening
rook e8 and um you know if rook dj queen
f7 wins
so after h5 rookie 8 just two checks and
please see one final decisive
move queen comes to h6 the game is just
over so this with this game wesley saw
equalized the score and it was 2-2
and the next day um they
played another four games and uh
they and magnu and wesley managed to win
the first game
so um let's let's see what happened so
basically
uh we can skip the opening part
but essentially magnus got a little bit
worse position of the
out of the opening in this position uh
okay here actually i want to start with
this position
uh wes is to play very nice with g3 an
idea of g3 to play h4 basically
whenever this knight is on g6 or b6 or
b3 or g3 idea of you know challenges
pawn
uh challenge design of the uh rook pawn
like right now we can change this
knight with h4 it's a very good idea
very often and that is to blame for h5
so here in this position mango simply
overestimated his chances
and he captured bishop takes h4
and he missed wesley's reply and the
game was just over in like
you know few moves and but this position
was already kind of difficult
and you know if he made something some
inaccuracy in the opening he got this
difficult position
because right now one has very nice
center
and the black it's it's hard for black
to come with some counter play
so uh he decides to hit this magnus
decided to just go bishop h4 and to try
to you know
complicate things but uh or maybe
i mean it was unnecessary it was of
course a mistake that he should have
played
uh sure castle for instance and but
anyway position
is bad is what i'm trying to say um
because after a short castle and we can
try also play h5 knight aj dylan tonight
on aj is not so good
of course it can come to game f6 be
knight f7 but okay not only is for now
is definitely a bad piece
we can consider playing h6 but also we
can play uh like simple uh bishop d3 i
think
after f6 simply queen e2 i hit the pawn
on a6 queen bc
b3 and followed by bishop b2 and of
course because such strong center y is
everywhere much better
it's just what goes about the question
um
why it's clearly much much better so uh
even though he played bishop takes h4 of
course this decide
speeds the process sort of uh of you
know
of white winning this game but as it was
obviously a mistake
but anyway white's pushing was very
pleasant and with great chances to win
the game
so uh but anyway he miscalculated that
after this this
uh white has very nice defensive idea of
e3 who comes through the third rank
so if you looked at the previous lesson
of um
on antony carpool's game against last
time horde
rook swings for the third rank this time
so um
you know uh the idea of karpov you know
can be applied sort of even in such
positions so that's why it's
uh really nice really really good no
such games
so right now uh wesley just is just
winning after five simply rui g3
who comes to this uh to predict the king
and
knight f3 follows you know if f takes e4
or something like queen g4 we can
always trade queens i mean not not
immediately but you know in the future
also idea of light f1 and so on the game
is just pretty much decided already
uh so in the game for short castle now
nice to meet you three
queen h5 knight d5 and the queens are
being swapped
and yeah the game is just over d6 and
here a few more moves but the result was
never the result was never in question
here magnus resigned
so it was the first blood right now in
the second day
of this match uh drawn and
wesley uh
uh one won the first man for won the
first encounter
and um magnus was ever since this
forced to basically chase the score and
he never got to do it even though he had
great chance i was we will see he had
great
great chances in uh following uh
following games
so let's say what happened in the second
game and this was very interesting
because
out of the opening it was i don't want
to discuss the opening it was all theory
kind of like italian game uh i think
mango's got a very promising position
after move
uh like let's say here in this position
he played another five
i think i think this position is very
promising and um
here um you know
basically magnus tries to win the pair
of bishops if bishop f6
there is possibility to play g4 and
knight e4 you know bringing the was nice
to the game
and uh you know bring the bishop to f4
bishop f5 g takes a five wins the light
square bishop especially three is
very very strong and uh i think uh that
uh you know white has some
unpleasant initiative at least and
that's why um
wesley plays some more solid rook ea but
this gives a possibility to give the
take the pair of bishops with nyx e7
and in this version it's just slightly
pure for white
but i want to ask you guys what would
you play
with white in this position after bishop
g6
why to play here what would you do
huh
simply an ig free and then f4 f5
uh possible but you're never gonna get
the f45 to work
i will play after knight g3 even i don't
know
knight c5 let's say
and i think our vision is great
bishop g5 uh already better move
uh but by some reason magnus then go for
it
queen e2 queen c4 uh queen c4 i guess
knight e5 i will play i don't quite like
this
we need to uh also possible starts like
bishop g5 is possible
uh knight g5 knight c5 again i liked for
the movie suggested
the most i think bishop g5 but passover
is magnus didn't go for it
and perhaps is my assumption that after
we should takes e4 we should take e7
or maybe maybe i'm wrong uh no i'm wrong
definitely
yeah maybe maybe this is also possible
bishop g5
however i wanted to uh show i mean i
want to show
explain the best move here for white in
my opinion we just move
f3 that's what i've said just said yes
f3
basically we are not worried here with
white about uh bishop
takes e4 because bureau takes e4 f takes
e4
opens the f5 for the queen and also uh
this pyro bishop will be much stronger
in pair of knights and we don't have to
really worry about this e5 square
as we'll see in a second um you know
white
i think has here a clear clear edge oh
sorry didn't mean to click on that again
i'm sorry i'm sorry
um f3 yeah h6 followed
uh bishop f4 very logical move knight c6
and rook e1 very logical as well
bringing the rook to the game
and right now uh wesley played bishop
bishop takes e4
and right now again we take the pawn on
e4
because we need to open the f file and
make use of this bishop on b3
because the rookie four phrases this
will run into knight c5 and basically
trading on b3 and e4 and basically the
game is just uh
close to being totally equal or is it
actually it is just totally equal
that's why i have to take the pawn and
to basically make use of this pair of
bishops
so right now knight c5 uh white black
has
yes very nice nice knife very nice very
nice and strong light on c for the
knight on e5 but pair of bishops is way
stronger
and uh you know design only five it does
only you know defensive tasks no
there's nothing else apart from that
bishop g3
look e8 um rook d1 idea right now
is to play queen f5 put some pressure on
those three squares f7 e5 and d7
so right now um let's decide to
you know simplify the question with
knight c5 and
right now i wanted to basically uh
i'll just discuss this position i will
ask us to ask you a question
but i wanted to discuss this position in
the basically right now there are two
possibilities
one possibility is to play what magnus
play bishop takes e5 which basically
leads to
by force to promising position i have to
say
but uh you know um some things are
getting you know simplified
and we'll see exactly what happened in a
second but
other another possibility right now is
playing bishop c2 and i like bishop c2
much
more and let's just see why because
we've kissed pair of bishops
knights are sort of like you know are
losing ground because uh
knight only five okay doesn't lose good
this knight doesn't lose ground but
um i don't think if c5 to the ground
let's say we want to play b4
to chase this knight away then play b
should be free back
and the knight will have to probably
just go back to d7 because otherwise i
don't know what this is
going to do only 5 is you know
will be have to be defended somehow uh
and 96 that's not possible because
leaves
this night undefended so 97 will have to
be played back simply right
but this is uh you know clearly to if
white has played before we should be
free
you know white can definitely be better
in this position that's why
i think uh here uh after bishop c2
markets would have retained really nice
chances to win the game
and uh liske would have had some
advantage but bishop takes e5
i think position is very close to
equality even though opposition is
promising
uh i think it's very close to equality
due to hd7
kingdom g7 it's b3 rotate e4 queen f3
and here magnus sorry wesley had one
chance to
immediately equalize and this move was
to play move rook e5
and this is huge this is very difficult
to understand say
you know especially during the game and
with your
rapid game or blizz game with a short
time control where rookie fighter
7 is better because he played with v7
seemingly very natural you know cover in
opponent f7
potentially you know cover pawns on c7
and b7
also very logical right but rugby five
is just
uh much stronger because basically after
rookie five we are looking for counter
play we are not
defending passively by defending the
response but we are going for
active counter play and uh rookie five
would have basically
pretty much kept the game equal because
through your phone right now queen e6
the point is that after uh queen b7
with rook on e7 white would be winning
but with work on e5 black has counter
player connected for rookie one and
that's the point
right now queenie free is a threat and
if rugged are traded and
you know right now rook takes one will
be just some sort of perpetual or you
know
sorry not perpetual but like you know
white king would be extremely weak
and here after 25 g frequent queen two
is not perpetual yet because queen g2
though can play simply a5 and it is hard
for
white to make any progress here because
four spawns in the queen side are sort
of just blocked
and the white black pawns are
you know well defended king is safe uh
it is extra pawn is pretty much
irrelevant
in my opinion so um still of course
white has sometimes
white has some choices because of the
extra pawn but this game this would have
came kept the game
just i think equal in instead west
played with e7 which i think was a big
mistake because right now uh
after uh rook not rook d4 routine for
the game is just by four mark
by magnus instead of this rook f1
followed by queen f6 would be a huge
basic problem because now queen six just
simply wins queen queen b7
and uh you know if not queen six i don't
know what to suggest pretty much because
queensland is just a big threat such a
big threat
if king g8 even uh i can you know go
queen g3
king here just uh rook f6 i believe oh
sorry aaron f6
refugee just queen of four like even
after queen traders a rook trade you
know this is a threat this is a threat
essentially black has to play like move
king james or something quinnish this
white wins the pawn
and this is much more much more
important point because you know right
now we have two versus one and those
pawns are actually going forward
so this would uh have given magnus huge
huge chance to win the game
it's like he played d4 also logical but
right now after queen six
uh followed by queenie free idea i think
mark westy solved all his problems and
the game
uh was he had the game full in control
uh
so the game they played a little bit
longer but at some point the queens were
swapped and
in the rook and game um wesley defended
well and the game was just just wrong
so missed chances here for magnus
the first missed chances in next game
wesley so
played with white against magnus and in
the opening
basically um in this position um
my yeah this position my wesley playing
bishop
ii was just a little bit odd i think
there was no reason to not to play
knight g3 and
that because i did frequent queen d3
doesn't it wins the pair of bishops but
uh it's pretty much irrelevant and i
think what could be slightly better
but bishop c2 is a little bit too
passive and right now uh magnum is
played very strong with queen c8 and the
idea of
you know bishop takes h2 going for ideas
connected with h3
and yeah because of that right now
um i think wesley is in big trouble
uh i mean not maybe big trouble yet but
let's say from practical perspective
it is very difficult to play for for
wesley it's very easy to blunder or sort
of
tricks with bishops h3 and so on for
instance right now i think the best move
for
white was to play h4 or knight from
three to
h2 which both moves are you know
difficult to play in my opinion
so um such move like we should be free
has been played but right now magnus
should have just trusted his god and
played shot takes h3 but he didn't do it
and this was his mischance i saw the
interview
and yeah he just missed that after i
think she takes the streak has moved a4
which is very important detail
because the point is that uh this bishop
has to be kicked out of you know this
diagonal in order for uh for black to
access e6 square sometimes and also
maybe
not to get simply pinned here in this
diagonal and
very important uh other thing is that
sometimes pawn on f7
is under uh some some pressure so for
example uh after
let's say y f4 is so important if quater
is h3 not not a4 but let's say queen
takes h3
uh then we should take the four knight
f4 knight e3
you know taking control over the g2
square and right now after rook e8
the point is that white can save the
game by playing knight g5 and right now
knight takes f7 orbital takes f7
and uh you know basically his position
after let's say queen g4 is still
dangerous because black can play rugby
six and so on but after
uh according to my arm according to my
analysis after ruby 6 95
queen f6 rook 81 position is sort of
balanced black somehow
uh doesn't have any decisive let's say
way to
continue here um according to my
according to my analysis obviously
so uh i think position just total
totally unclear
uh however if we include move a4
none of this happens because after we
play f4 the same line happens
but right now bishop is not there and
rookie six uh first of all there is no
knight g5 knight f7 because bishop is
misplaced
and bishop best move incidentally just
to go bishop b3 but right now we can
play even d5
or even rook e6 both with huge chances
for black to you know to
to attack and but let's say d5 of things
better we're just
preparing we see through g6 ideology is
that basically
we want to even uh we have to basically
play after xc and now this
comes there so also it's very promising
however it's a little bit less clear i
think d5 is just better because after
knight g5 queen h6
um you know let's say queen g4 and we
can just play queen g5 and basically
this is the best what white can go for
and here black has just a clear extra
pawn and
great winning chances because of this
fork and black
black has great wing chances here so
this was
the best rhino try for for magnus but he
played it xd4
and right now uh an afternoon xd4 uh
when positions back again at equal
i think a little bit safer with bishop
take this just to get rid of this bishop
on the light square bishops just in case
and um but afrika knight xd4 followed we
should take d4
and ryan right now again uh magnus uh
sorry wesley made a big mistake because
he takes the queen takes d4
uh what kept the balance with c takes d4
and position is very close to equal
you know because none of this bishop h3
stuff works right now
for instance after this bishop takes f4
first takes takes
queen takes h3 knight e3 queen g4 is the
idea
and if rook a8 yeah just queen g4 simply
trace the
uh trace the queens and even though
black has some counter play here we
still have rook to 84 and so on
uh at best will be three points for a
piece but uh white
is not getting mated i think white is
pretty much safe in this position after
you say takes takes
king g2 i think you know uh position is
pretty much safe for white
and uh maybe even slightly better maybe
at some point that's so that's why stage
four was
very very strong and the simplest you
know path here for for wesley
but he played quintus for by some reason
and right now uh
magnus was winning with knight hd2 and
uh
this was again missed chance by magnus i
think the idea of the point is after
king takes g2
which plays the h3 king h2 and now
knight h4
93 is a big threat so the only way to
face this threat or the best logical
most logical has to play queen d1 but
right now there's possibly like
bishop g2 followed by queen edge
frequent each one which just checked
mating
attack and the game is just totally over
so yeah just just over there is mating
attack i think bishop gt is what magnus
missed
and uh yeah here is just over
so again missed opportunity for magnus
with knight takes g2
uh he played bishop takes b3 and right
now again
um this time wesley play automatically
takes b3
which again is a mistake so this game
here was like you know sort of like a
tragic comedy of errors for both sides
because again we should take the four
was you know
keeping the balance after it takes takes
the point is that we need to simplify
the position not to make
in order not for black's attack not to
be that strong
and yeah after you know here it takes b5
a6b3 i mean again uh knight x h3 was
causing
would have basically won the game again
on the spot uh because after or
no we wouldn't have won the game because
uh after king h2 knight f4
black has simply extra pawn okay queen
d6 is still possible but there is some
knight hd2 possible as well
i assume or like even queen g4 black has
a strong attack
and if g takes h3 and this is losing for
white
because of knight h4 right now and after
queen rider 3 is coming
so queen d1 has to be played and now
queen h3 basically with checkmating fret
and uh
knight f3 no way to stop from
the sub black from both so after it
takes uh b3 again missed chance for
magnus knight x3 he didn't do it play
moved d5
and d5 was a huge mistake because after
right now uh
right now wesley had a huge chance to
overtake actually to play bishop takes
f4 attacks for queen d2 and
suddenly white wins the pawn the knight
has to probably go back and
somebody takes on d5 because the thing
is if queen c7 tried to defend this
knight
now g3 and knight the white cannot go
for this because after king g2 knight is
dropped
and you know design has nowhere to go
and the white
sort of uh just uh wins of course black
employment like 27 but again this knight
is trapped and
white will be able to deliver a win here
uh yeah so uh
you know wesley played queen d2 uh by
some reason and right now
at 83 the game was the game the game got
extremely messy
eventually the game ended with uh draw
none of the sites had really any big
chances uh maybe
one or two moments has some chance here
but it was nothing really conclusive i
guess and uh
i think because no nothing as conclusive
as let's say here earlier that hg2 or
knight is h3 or bishop takes h3 those
were the main missed chances here for
miners so
um yeah unfortunately here for manus he
didn't take
advantage of his chances and uh in the
game
in the end the game ended with some
crazy end game
like this but wesley managed to hold
this
or maybe more like magnus managed to
hold this anyway position just around
equal
and the game ended with logical results
which was a draw
so um finally uh let's
let's show you the this
is how it ended so finally the last game
uh here are basically
just i think one or two moments where
basically it could have been you know
something
really important happened uh basically
starting with this position
um you know positions totally unclear
but here right now martin
wesley made a huge mistake with black
playing with knight takes d4
that takes four was a big mistake
because it allows white to create a very
strong center
instead queen f6 will have kept the game
totally unclear
but i have turned xd 464 i think white
has big advantage because of queen d3
there is no reason to be worried about
the weakened pawn structure on the king
side
because in reality black king is
extremely weak and this will have
happened in the game
after takes takes bishop h y has very
strong center after bishop of h5
e5 very nice move opening the center
for the queen and diagnose for the queen
for the bishop and so on
and d5 bishop b3 white has pretty much
crushing attack
so uh last final question here for you
guys
after if you follow the game uh you for
sure know the solution but
uh if you didn't so here's the problem
what to do here with white after move a4
this is the last position for today
and after which we will conclude so uh
but i think it's good to leave it at
this moment because it was the main
missed chance here for magnus there
everything else later in the game
was also winning uh he had some chances
of course but
you know nothing was as clear as it was
right now in this particular moment find
the win for white
e6 is not good i'll just take your
bishop
queen f5
okay uh i mean e6 okay you can play this
but i will just give your bishop like
your bishop if you play e7 i will just
give up the exchange the
rook i'll be the only exchange down and
this is not completely unclear
um other move queen f5
just bishop g6 i think i win but king h1
yes king h1 king h1 is the best move
the point is right now basically we are
going after this king there is no reason
to uh defense bishop
on b3 and uh basically right now
i just play with g1 and just checkmate
then the point is after king
after 8xb3 through g1 king aj and now
all white would do
the key move of the combination
the key move is right now the king of
kings one combination
is to play right now what
e6 correct there we go e6 and basically
bishop comes to a5 and the game is just
over
the game is just over bishop comes to a5
and just checkmating attack let's say
after f6 we can just play queen f5
queen e8 bishop e5 is just totally over
and yeah and the game is over
pretty much bishop g6 right now uh we
could buy broadcaster with this as well
but again rg1
king h7 uh rook to hg6 pawn takes
uh simply rogue g1 bringing final pieces
again to the game after rook f5 simply
bishop c2
it's simply over it's totally over so
yeah
okay the rest of the game there there
was some some still some chances here
for magnus as well
um but this was not uh
so i think important and
i think the king h1 was uh the key idea
that magnus
made okay for he's soaking h1 but he
didn't see e6 so
this was his main missed chance in this
game because the rest was already
very unclear even though according to
engines he was still winning
and had some great chances but it wasn't
at the same human level that clear as it
was after king h1 and then finding with
finding e6
so yes that's all i have i think for
today
i think i covered pretty much all the
important moments or
almost all important moments from all
the games that
you know they played and that's all i
have
so i hope it was instructive so take
care guys
i will see you next time have a good
evening bye